English from London
lond what your name
a lot a lot of people that are in
talking to they seem to have a problem
with the idea of English
M what do you mean how oh no you can't
be English Muslim tell your Funny Story
Once I Was giv dawa outside the sheet
Bush Central Line Station giv that is a
young lady English lady and she said you
know makes sense to me so I said become
a Muslim she like I'm not Pakistani
I said you don't have to be a Pakistani
to be a Muslim there English Muslim
French Muslim Arab Muslim so Islam is
not for the Arabs the proof that Islam
is not for the Arabs when the prophet
Muhammad came with Islam who went
against him his own tribe went against
him so even you hear this nonsense that
hijab is is Arab Clause how is Arab
Clause before Prophet Muhammad came the
woman in qur they to a hij but this is
due to like of knowledge and ignorance
you understand so Islam and this is the
beauty of Islam Buddhism Buddha
Christianity Christ Judaism Judah Islam
not the prophet Muhammad Islam
submitting to Allah alone so no yeah
there's no no God worthy of worship in
truth except Allah there is no God no no
no but this is is there another God
there's other God besides Allah but we
call them false gods that's what Allah
in the Quan so that's why that's why
translation the correct translation
for cuz I see people mistranslate they
say there's no good but God this
incorrect translation the correct
translation no is because why I'll tell
you why when you translate a language
you are translating the meaning correct
okay so if you CH the meaning Allah in
the Quran explain the meaning of which
Allah in the
Quran going into meaning
but in in the articulation of the words
it's pretty direct isn't it yeah but
again only translate you translate the
meaning yeah but you're adding mean dep
no because you're M translating
it I don't think so yeah because why
when someone say it's easy to understand
what is
it doesn't mean it means a universe of
mean there a universe no that's what it
means meaning meaning I agree with we're
not going to end finish with the meaning
no no no no no there's only one meaning
which prophet mam came
with the meaning Allah explained it so
for example if I say something to you
you cannot say Shi meant this way if I'm
myself I'm explain what I meant so if
Allah himself explained what is the
meaning of ill we stick with the meaning
that Allah explained it to us that's the
beaut of isem we keep it real and pure
and authentic we don't add and we don't
move
alhamdulillah but it can't be translated
there no good back no you m translating
it that's the point it's a transation I
know it's a translation but what I'm
saying is Mis transation what whatever
whatever translation is going to miss
something no no it's like saying oh the
Holy Quran you can translate it like
this and like that it's a translation
you have to accept would you translate
the meaning but you have to accept even
with the best
intention and guidance it's it's going
to fall short yeah no doubt I mean it
will give you something it it will it
will draw you towards some some some
something some truth some understanding
but it's going to fall short but it's a
translation yeah but when he say there's
no God but God it's like saying you know
just to argue against
that it's okay to say there's no God but
yeah but they say Okay Christian believe
Jesus Is God so there's Gods other gods
and which God you referring to to begin
with well we're saying
God I'm not Arabic it's not my language
you so that's why you say there's
no one the one dat the one deserves to
be woried that's why you say okay so
this is the depth of the meaning which
is unexplained it that's why we s to the
meaning which Allah explained to remove
any doubt or any deficiency we can we
can we can say the Christians can say
this God is on the cross there and and
that one can
say there my family of Gods on the
mantle piece here and they can say all
day long but it doesn't change the
reality does it that you're right that's
why when say there's no God worthy of
worship in truth so you negate because
what the Quran said Allah affirmed other
gods
besides worthy they're not even they
don't even qualify as they worthy yeah
they're not even
you know they don't equake at all yeah
but so that's what Allah in the Quran
affirms there's other gods beside him
but Allah said they are the false gods
and it affirmed that he the true God so
therefore careful I will pull you up on
the on the language there that there's
other gods beside him it is not saying
surely I mean forgive my ignorance yeah
but surely he's not saying that God he
says no no it's not that one it's
there's
many in in the sense only in the sense
that they are
falsehoods they're not they're not
realities they are imagin people's
imaginations all that Allah explained
what is the meaning of should we stick
to the explanation of Allah or we should
go another explanation we should stick
to the explanation of Allah I'm going to
stick with there's no God but God and
that no no but that doesn't mean to say
that I agree with what you're saying but
what I'm saying is that it shouldn't it
shouldn't be uh left aside it's it's
okay it has it has Merit to say there is
no God but God has Merit but you're not
giv and and and and from what my I'm
receiving from you is that that should
be struck
off such a phrase yeah because why that
phrase is not giving Justice to what how
Allah explain I'm not able to AG yeah
but you need to learn first you need to
learn first before you can say Lear
first yeah but you need to learn first
why who are you to teach me to learn
because if you learn Arabic you know
that Allah says Al speak in English but
what does Allah reveal it
in we have to Humble ourselves in it I
humbled myself I didn't know English or
Arabic I learn it what language when you
learn it exactly what language
spoke is not language a tribe is a
dialect it's that basically it's that
basically someone said to you spoke
English no have Lio dialect but it's
still English you understand so a
dialect Arabic so please don't embarass
yourself next time anyway I'm say
respect I'm telling you the meaning
Allah so we stick to the meaning which
Allah explain that's my point after you
take it or
not bless